what's the most major threat on the  world stage Venezuela is the single  greatest resource of oil on the planet  so why is this country in the midst one  of the greatest humanitarian crises in  history  [Music]  [Applause]  your concern is that the Russians are  secretly selling weapons to Venezuela  they would fit a pattern  this ends up in the news is just gonna  cause panic in nuclear Venezuela you  will not hear about in the news because  we'll already be dead  business a pleasure jack I'm here for  work  what happened Reyes was his name ever  Mitch be nice stay you have no  protection nobody's coming to save us we  do this we do this guy I can live with  that  you  you